what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sockin very excited to
be talking about investing in frontier
tech we have Jeff klaviyo joining us on
the show hi Jeff
how you doing thanks so much for coming
on the program thank you so much for
having me
I'm so pumped for this conversation
those who don't know Jeff's background
he is a veteran of the Forbes midas list
of top venture capitalists in the world
he's founder and Managing Partner of
uncork capital one of the original seed
VC firms in Silicon Valley with over
five hundred million dollars under
management having closed 200-plus
investments since 2004 including in
companies like Fitbit Eventbrite
bleacher report post mates bitly and in
companies that were acquired by Intuit
Game Stop Yahoo eBay Google and Twitter
they're currently investing out of their
100 million dollar fund six making on
average 15 seed commitments of 1 million
dollars per year in mobile cloud SAS
consumer services connected devices
marketplaces and frontier tech including
AI AR VR autonomous vehicles digital
manufacturing material science space
tech and synthetic biology you can find
all of their links in the bio below
encore capital comm as well as Jeff's
Twitter profile what a cool job to be
able to see all of those fields and how
they're impacting our world and be able
to help fund the creative minds that are
trying to build the future it is the
best job in the world we see the future
through the eyes of entrepreneurs and
we're very lucky that were limited
partners to people invest in us and
trust us with a very broad-based
sort of set of topics we can invest in
and so we're having a lot of fun
it's amazing to sort of meet people this
morning I just had a meeting with
someone was building robots that were
vacuuming offices and the guy was super
passionate about it and it was just an
awesome time we spent talking about
vacuuming and robots
and this is a massive part of our future
automation robotics AI autonomous
perception systems and just where is
this all taking us and what is the
nature of this reality that we even find
ourselves in the first place do you find
yourself having the deep these like
deeper also philosophical conversations
with your friends families colleagues
the people you invest in about you know
why are we even here what what is the
purpose of this reality that we're in we
I think as V sees we try and sort of
figure out what is the future that we're
gonna try and build and then work
backward to actually sort of okay what
does that mean to have this sort of
vision 20-year vision 50-year vision
which is what it takes sometimes we
think about artificial intelligence full
autonomy and things like that
but then be practical enough to figure
out what can I actually invest in today
which will make you know progress in the
next couple of years to actually raise
the next one of financing and so there's
the aspiration there's the this is what
I want to build but then you come back
to earth because there's always the need
to raise more money at some point and so
that that sort of keeps us grounded on
doing things which are actual sort of
practical developments which can go to
market within you know a few years what
we do and I think you know for us
frontier tech is where we've a lot of
ourselves to invest in companies where
there's not an immediate sort of good to
market opportunity you're sort of saying
well I'm gonna turn the corner and I'm
gonna assume there's a market for it and
we know that fangio tech is is very
tricky for that because you know no one
really knows when autonomous vehicle
technology will actually be ready for
primetime
you know it's soon and every day we're
getting closer but it's not clear to me
whether it's one year five years or ten
years I like how you put this in terms
of the
both how you feel and how the people
that you work with and the entrepreneurs
that are trying to build the future the
way that you guys see it happening is
you see the new world that you want to
build and then you look at kind of
today's physical reality and you see
what our this may be some of the archaic
systems in place how do they work what
are the ways that we can actually
physically execute and implement this
and get it into the path the trajectory
that actually builds that new world and
you have to be very both bold and
imaginative and have this really sort of
big vision but then have the
practicality of actually making it
happen and one of the big questions that
we ask ourselves before make an
investment is why now right what are the
key changes in terms of technology or
society or you know acceptance social
acceptance for example of a given you
know technology or service or or concept
that will actually make it happen and
sometimes the why now actually fails
because it's not why now you know it's
like not now it actually is too early
people will just not you know go and get
into a you know self-driving car because
it's just too risky because the
technology you know it works except at
the edge and and we've heard
unfortunately you know people dying
because of that edge failed edge cases
failures and we'll see right whether
people actually sort of go for it so
acceptance of social acceptance show or
risk acceptance is a big factor in our
decision making
hmm that's so hard so you're you're
you're seeing both the current state of
the world the future that you want to
build the entrepreneur themselves and
kind of their their own kind of
blueprint what is their blueprint are
they doing exactly what they're meant to
do in this world do they can you feel it
radiating from them that they're
supposed to be doing and we need to feel
that
because unlike you know when I went when
I started my own journey on in
entrepreneurship being an entrepreneur
in France 25 years ago 30 years ago
basically meant that you couldn't find a
job and so you basically had to build
your own company because no one would
give you a job and when I told my dad
that was gonna get into the started game
a long time ago now thirty years ago the
usual reaction was I don't understand
you voice that good grades and you're
like what
come on I'm telling you about what I
want to do and then you talk about
grades because there was this issue
behind well you've been successful at
school so you should find a good job and
by definition being an entrepreneur is
not being a you know it's not a good job
at all it's very you know unsecured the
windows whether you'll be able to put
food on the table and so on so forth and
so I think over the you'll see that
changing the world and building the
future in your own way
right and so you need to see that
dedication to the mission and the vision
and the fact that we try and get the
sense that people will be able to walk
through walls because that's what it
takes to actually be an entrepreneur cuz
it's so so hard and some some sectors
are even harder than others so it's
never easy to build a great software
company but it's much more difficult to
build a great hardware company and if
you add you know like the complexity of
some of those new sectors like
autonomous vehicles I think it's
probably one of the hardest things that
you can try and build to that because
it's love sensor or the hardware a lot
of that out of AI lots lots of
regulations and so it's just you're
really trying to hurt yourself by trying
to build those companies but what we try
to figure out is this burning desire the
entrepreneur that even if I tell you for
three hours all the issues are gonna
face at the end
and you'll still say yep but I just
can't stop myself I have to do it
yeah and so that that's sort of this
commitment that determination that we
want to see cuz you know resilience is
probably the the number one
characteristic that we want to see in
entrepreneurs before they start because
they will fail you know on the ground
and have to go back up get back up and
and try and make things work because
it's never a straight path it's riddled
with failures small failures launch
failures and you know you have to find
the the impulse to get out of bed every
morning after a big failure and and get
back to work I want to hit the ball back
with with two of the thoughts that you
listed there one of them is these walls
that you talked about so I want to know
that for all of those to hear from you
about this from all of those that are
aiming to build that future and there's
all these different walls that are
coming up in the way we talk about this
a lot on the show as those walls are our
gifts that we get to overcome and we get
to learn and then we get to teach other
people about how we overcame them and
other people can then kind of go over
those walls maybe more effectively and
so and walls is one of them and then the
other one was kind of figuring out how
to be humble along that path because
even though you're resilient right that
if you're so resilient that maybe when
you're getting good advice maybe from a
venture capitalist like yourself or
maybe when you're getting really good
advice from a mentor that if maybe how
can gauge if that advice is actually the
right thing for your trajectory and for
overcoming those walls to get to that
new world
so uh so humidity I mean I like people
humble in their approach I like people
who are super
smart yet sort of listen to the ideas of
others the thing with an entrepreneur
you have to be humble enough to
understand the reality in which you know
you're living in and you know the
constraints that you have to deal with
but you shouldn't be so humble enough to
not try so there is this fine balance
between being humble enough but not too
much and having a bit of that you know
Swagger and and and you know trying to
just go for it
because that's what you need to be
successful so it's it's really sort of
and in what's hard for us is trying to
figure this out because we're gonna
spend a lot of time with non-super
numbers right eight to ten years on
average for success well it comes in
people in the portfolio and the numbers
are staggering this is around ninety six
percent of all businesses don't make it
after ten years yeah and so so we're
gonna spend a lot of time with them but
we spend so little time getting to know
that because if you look at the typical
sort of process that we go through
before making an investment we're gonna
meet you know entrepreneurs three or
four times we're gonna spend a total of
maybe five to ten hours and we try and
sort of figure out everything about the
business about you know the team about
the motivation about the potential about
the market and so on so forth which VC
is called due diligence which we call
due diligence absolutely and there is
there is little time for actually
figuring out the personal aspect and we
try and sort of do that dub you know one
of the things that we do at the firm is
we will always make sure that one of us
meets the entrepreneur face-to-face
which is actually sometimes the tricky
because they may be you know in New York
or somewhere else in the u.s. at least
we invest you know in US companies but
we now have more and more international
founders so the hey we need to meet mean
someone jumps in the plane and you gain
a greater understanding of that due
diligence from the eye to eye in the
person you want to meet the person
because this is something that
is part of our decision-making process
because sometimes people are great you
know in a zoom video remotely and
they're sort of awkward you know face to
face and and and vice versa you could
have someone who's actually not great
through a video conversation because you
have this you know digital sort of
intermediary in the middle but is
actually great in a face-to-face setting
so we try and we try and sort of figure
this out so that's that's for humble the
walls is basically all the issues you're
gonna face as as a start-up entrepreneur
and yes which fine so the key thing at
least in the way we think about our
java's Osby ceases we'll never tell you
what to do what not to do we'll just
tell you in a circumstance like this one
which we're facing this is what this
company or this entrepreneur or you know
this person in the portfolio has faced
as issues and this is what happened and
this is what we did to try and fix it so
the story tell about other other times
that entrepreneurs have faced similar
walls and how they overcame or how they
maybe fail to overcome system so that
part of the storytelling is hey I'm not
telling you I'm just trying to bring my
experience so you know expertise and an
story of 15 years of investments and and
many many many failures failures to try
and help you make the right decisions
but it's very hard to say oh this is
like this company in this situation and
so you should do this so you should do
that because they're right every company
is different timing is different and you
know I can tell you well Fitbit did this
you know 10 years ago but maybe is
completely irrelevant
so easy more like here is a frame of
mind and here is the decision-making
process that we used so that you can
then analyze that and then regurgitate
and figure out what you want to do so
it's very hard unfortunately or
fortunately to have like a
playbook that you can take from a very
successful company and apply it to
another one or another one like I could
tell you know the successful journey of
Fitbit to all my hardware companies but
doesn't really mean anything to them
because they're all very different
tactics can be useful mmm-hmm right but
the this notion of hey there's there's a
big wall here it could be regulatory it
could be sort of good to market it could
be you know production because actually
building physical things is very very
hard yeah especially at the right you
know on time on quality in on spec and
so all those things it's not because
something worked for one company will
work for others actually it's pretty
much certain that this works for this
one bit won't work for that one this
really takes me in many ways to tribal
storytelling about successes that we had
with maybe like immediate return
hunter-gathering where you went and you
found the optimal places to gather the
optimal ways to hunt and you told the
stories to the other people in the tribe
in this way it's telling the other
stories to the entrepreneurs that are
facing these challenges and helping them
navigate through their journeys in
building that future Jeff for those that
may be a little bit this is this is very
abstract thing to try and wrap our minds
around but there's somehow money you
know is being put into funds and then so
you're pitching people to trust because
you have a record a track record and
they believe in you to manage their
money to invest into companies in the
seed around 1 million dollar investment
level and then and then you give those
people you know you take about ten or so
percent at that at that seed investment
level and then you give them all these
other things these these mentorship
around the walls this stuff and but then
there's you know the
all these numbers and cap tables and
then you have to reward those initial
people that you had to pitch so you're
pitching people to for your fun to then
invest it tell us about the complexity
of that sheer system I mean you
summarized it well that's essentially
the way the way this goes so 15 years
ago so I have been a VC for four years
before I started in Cork and that's
where I learned the basis of what it
means to be a VC which was very useful a
lot of the people who are entering the
seed space these days alt actually sort
of VC trained which means that they
discover on the on the job what means to
be a vision that's tricky so my first
three years I was just a business
business central so I actually
circumvented the like I walked around
one wall which was fundraising so I
convinced my wife to take 250 K ever or
savings we have made a little bit of
money at at Reuters which was the
acquirer of my company not a ton and so
we said hey 2050 is gonna be the initial
budget we're gonna do a handful of
investments 25 50k checks and and mostly
where it goes and so 2007 is when I
raised my first institutional fund and
essentially that's what happened that
told the story which was what there is a
gap in the funding market as bizarre as
people sort of may think it is today to
think about a funding gap where there
was not there weren't that many people
funding entrepreneurs doing seed states
of tech back in 2006-7
it's true and so I raised one of the
first micro VC funds as we sort of call
them at that time and I told a story
about the potential to a story about you
know these companies and what they were
doing and why it would be a great idea
to raise a small fund to write small
checks to help them sort of get going
and and the idea was you take a small
risk in terms of capital but you get
massive leverage because you invest very
early at a low valuation and if the
Penny's become multibillion-dollar
outcomes then you'll make a lovely and
at the end of the day the people we
pitch the investors we call them limited
partners are trusting us VCS with their
capital because the returns are better
than the public market because otherwise
you can just invest in the SNP and you
know here you go
and so the pitch is hey I'm gonna take
$100 from you
and because we're sit stage takes a long
time for companies to be successful and
in you know eight years I will return
$500 or more mm-hm
four or five hundred dollars or more
you're pointing at something else also
which is potentially the future of micro
investing if people can put in even as
little as just a hundred dollars into
such a fun like yours and gain that much
in LA in that case it's small millions
as yeah yeah yeah but I mean eventually
we'll sort of figure those things out
yeah and you know if people sort of find
your initial track record convincing and
your thesis interesting and your story
actually sort of works on them then they
will so write you a check which is
typically you know a few million dollars
and you'll tell the story a bunch of
times and most people will say no oh and
eventually you'll raise a fund and over
time we got lucky with fun too because
it was literally and and it was abnormal
to raise such a weird new type of fund
in such a short time he was basically
eight weeks also in the summer of 2007
just before the financial crash and then
you know racing next fund was much
longer and and eventually if you succeed
then raising money becomes something
that happens very quickly so we're last
fund fund six as you mentioned was
raised in just a few short weeks Wow
a few short weeks to get a hundred
million dollar net fund that you raised
to funds of a hundred million dollar
each so we raise 200 million dollars in
a few short weeks Wow yeah and then now
the next the next
around this is so then how do you and
then the these are limited partners that
are coming in and putting in the the
funding how do you what what's say do
the limited partners get on where the
money goes what say do you and your
partners at uncork it and where the
money goes and then what do you what do
you also like recommend for people in
terms of observing the emerging
technologies that are coming into our
world and and how to kind of keep an eye
on the complexity of that so typically
you try and give yourself the maximum
flexibility in terms of where things go
so what you're gonna once again you're
gonna tell a story to limited partners
is one that we call Potiphar
construction so you're going to give
them rough parameters in our case we'll
invest in 30 ish companies over three
years average investment will be
$1,000,000 ish and we'll try and get as
you said you know 10% ish and the ish is
actually important because it gives you
flexibility I'm not trying to get like
10% a million dollar 30 companies no
that's too restricted rigid I'm
basically giving them a sense of what
they can expect I've been very clear
with them that we invest in a lot of
different you know categories and types
of technologies on so forth including
that crazy you know frontier tech sector
where the probability of success is low
which means you can expect an even
greater
you know percentage of failures in that
category but we may actually sort
uncover you know really interesting
multi-billion dollar outcomes in that in
that sector and they sign up for that
and you try and put in your legal you
know contract which we call the limit
the limited partnership agreement as few
limitations and and rules and boundaries
as possible
so I think we can't for example invest
more than 10% of the fund in any one
company without asking over board for
permission those kinds of things but in
terms of individual investments they
have absolutely zero say whoa not
interest and and that's the way it
should because either the trust you
investor and essentially it's think of
it as hey so here is here is $100 the
same hundred dollar wake me up when you
sort of send me back money and and
otherwise good luck to you and obviously
we're gonna give them progress reports
we actually serve issue report every
quarter and we do an audited financial
you know report once a year so it's
actually pretty formal yeah yeah but
they don't they come say oh I don't like
this investment I don't want it this is
a word our own decision and that's
that's do it should be do those same
principles go to the next level so when
you put in the million dollars into the
entrepreneur how much do you then get a
say in what the entrepreneur is doing
well as little as possible in the sense
that you know it's a entrepreneurs
company and you know we invest super
early so and we own 10% so does nobody
control whatever like literally if they
don't want to listen to us they don't
listen to us and to be candid we try and
figure this out before we make an
investment decision is whether the
entrepreneur is going to be coachable
and whether they actually gonna listen
to us cuz yeah it's their company we
will never tell them what to do what not
to do but we'll give them advice we'll
tell them stories about things that
happen to other companies and we want to
make sure that they actually listen to
the data points that we'll share with
them because that's really what we bring
to the table is
you know 15 years of investing at seed
stage 219 companies to date right
that we've seen go from zero to success
or zero to failure but there's always a
bunch of key learnings that we can share
and it's up to the entrepreneur to I
think respect those the relevant stories
that we tell them and there's no point
in telling irrelevant stories so that if
they take those into account before they
sort of make their own decisions and so
it's their company is their decisions we
try and give them just as as much as we
can from our experience and expertise
and and data points to make those
decisions as informed as possible in the
world of you know where everything is
super early therefore super you know
it's like you have a lens and it's
unfocused and use therefore sort of see
a bunch of shadows and you can't really
sort of see what's there you see you
know there is something there and we
just tell them well in similar
situations this is what the shadow was
about mm-hmm and then you were on the
board of the National VC Association yes
okay for four years yes and just 2015 in
2019
yes and as doing that and you guys
sharing best practices around what how
to how to make the efficiencies and what
you're doing but also I'm curious if you
guys are also talking about then when
about these emerging technologies and
how you're figuring out what are the
places that you're you know you listen
so many different fields how do you guys
keep track of the different fields and
yeah that's that's a really great
question so the National Venture Capital
Association is really sort of the the
body that represents the industry with
regulators and government right so this
is
is we have a team of 10 each people in
Washington and they spend a lot of time
on the hill to make sure that senators
house members understand you know what
tech is about what we need from them
what sort of what are the implications
of any regulation or you know
limitations or things that they want to
sort of set up as part of their
day-to-day work because they don't
really understand at all what we do on
the financing side on building startups
this sort of see or at least until we
sort of did a good job educating them
they was just like this thing in
California and startups were only about
you know San Francisco and Palo Alto and
it's definitely not the case so we try
and really one educate and represent on
one side and then bring all the concerns
that senators and House members may have
and work with you know our companies to
try and get tech and Washington to work
better together in these days it's
actually really really hard what a
crucial thing to get done though okay
yes you guys also as VCS are also
slightly unfamiliar with congressional
processes and so absolutely that way
it's synergizes that is very very true I
was I was you know surprised / shocked
when I when I showed up as a newly
minted sort of bull number of the NDC a
which is a four-year service and it's
good that it's four years you know of
service because the first year you're
like literally learning money you're
like what the hell is going on and yeah
they don't like when you show up like
this it's it's really like suits and
ties and tucked our forever because like
showing it like that like that is you're
out and so there's a formality that is
sort of amusing but but necessary
because you know this is this is formal
job so the
the symbiosis which is always sort of
hard to establish is very very important
because otherwise they will make I would
say wrong decisions in terms of rules
regulations decisions they will make but
they will serve impact startups in a
negative way and anything that impacts
startups in a negative way potentially
has an impact on the economy and so yeah
because if you look at the impact of
successful startups and impact on
creativity I'm building the new world
and and jobs and you know revenues and
everything as well right so that's why
this role was was really interesting to
your point about how do we keep updated
with what's going on in in the world of
technologies and so forth it's about
keeping track of the key sectors that
you're interested in it's about going
after you know going to conferences
meeting you know scientists having key
experts you can trust and you will tap
for advice and pointers and and things
like that but at the same time remember
that as we see most of what we see comes
inbound to us so people are seeking you
know capital and you know we're
fortunate to have a great brand and
great track record and people sort of
come to us and we rarely sort of go and
seek someone to invest in them what we
do seek is advice and validation about
you know going back to my robotic vacuum
cleaner thing that I made this morning
if ever I was interested I would go and
seek advice about you know the
commercial vacuum market because I know
nothing about it
I recently committed to a company in the
lab grown diamonds space yeah I knew
nothing about lemon diamonds at all you
know they're also doing it for weeks ago
hair they're doing it with hair human
hair
with ashes yep - a turnover is such an
interesting thing that you can take some
of your child's hair and and do the
high-pressure carbon process that give
your like wife a diamond of your like
child's hair like such a interestingly
filled that's and so you know the you
know the to make an investment in
something like this you have to spend
you know of time and talk to you know
experts and get sort of advice
validation about the technology and then
figure out the de market is kind of big
enough and so you answered the key the
key questions about founder and founder
market fit product and you know market
opportunity and if ever the three sort
of come back positive then and you sort
of like the entrepreneur and you see all
the passion and everything we talked
about then you are to check yeah and
then how about on the the processes that
actually occur with figuring out the you
know your we're talking about this
earlier this this this energy this aura
that you feel from the entrepreneur
their vision for building that future
their ability to do so their coach
ability all these these these really
crucial things do you guys do you guys
have some sort of like a process of also
knowing knowing what future you want as
as as Jeff and ass uncork you guys have
this future that you want to this future
world that wants to exist and then do
you guys kind of find the investment
pieces so if you guys say we want that
we want to stop slaughtering animals we
want to grow meat and bioreactors so you
go okay so now this fund we're gonna
have a an investment in the lab grown
meat space and then you also say that
you want to help people that may have
some sort of learning disability or so
this cognitive disability to then have
an augmentation of sorts through
augmented reality interfaces new
input-output interfaces that helps them
communicate with other people in the
world
so do you then go in kind of like fonts
you see the vision and then you fund the
the entrepreneurs that kind of help
build that the new world so what you're
describing is either a thesis driven
sort of firm that will have a set of
whiteboards and say those are the the
key sort of sectors or the key feature
services that we want to find a solution
for and that's what they will go and do
and that's just not our approach because
of the breadth what we do so at the end
of the day and my wife runs the Center
for Social Innovation at Stanford and
she's into impact investing and social
entrepreneurship and the bottom line and
she always say don't don't even pretend
that what you guys do is impact you guys
justice you know after the money I'm
like yeah but you know when companies
like molecule improves the quality of
the air were breathing and helps people
who have asthma to avoid ending up in ER
because they cleaned up the air that
they had in their bedroom yeah it's
actually sort of a positive impact and
she says yes and that's making the world
better so it's a world positive kind of
investment and so that's that's sort of
the angle we try and make the world a
better place as people that's a work
that's a statement yeah but then we just
see all those opportunities that come to
us inbound and we're always thrilled to
see them sort of improving people's
situation example we have a company
called vivid vision
CH company in the pond5 and what those
guys do is they use today's VR
technology so goggles that you can find
from you know Icarus or even to give you
are from Samsung and they have developed
special programs to treat amblyopia
which is you know crazy eyes
cost iron things like that and thanks to
you know those treatments within a
couple of years you can basically have
someone no longer have any amblyopia
within a couple of years
at any age at any age any age which is
really sort of brand-new because you
know the traditional technique which is
based on trying to exercise you know
your eyes with masks and some so forth I
think there's a limit of you know either
18 or 25 years old where you can't after
that you can't really sort of do
anything and this company is basically
you know there's I think 30 million
people in the u.s. we have in the OPI
and each will be treated by you know the
vision yeah and so this is the type of
stuff that we love talking about on the
show so much when you have this this tie
between money and power and status with
building the future in a way that is
truly about the highest possibility that
our world can be
we love that so much and that that that
processes is if that that to hear that
from you inspires us and then hopefully
we hope to see other because there's
some bad there's some people that also
feel and this comes from that the
actions that people both observe and the
way that people behave themselves but
just that there can sometimes be just a
focus on money just to focus on power
and the status and so it's great to hear
you talking about the social but there's
a point I wanted to make is that I had
no idea like trying to sort of improves
people's you know condition within be
Opia oh people who have him be okay
improve the condition wasn't sort of
something I woke up to one day and said
oh I'm gonna go and do that which is
wasn't your thesis it was yeah it was
just like hey we try and leverage
technology to in general sort of make
the world a better place and sometimes
we succeed in making like a dent you
know in whatever the world's misery is
or you know but condition
whatever and that makes us sort of feel
pretty good but at the end of the day
we're measured you know rightly or
wrongly by our success in returning a
bunch of money to our investors because
that's what we need you know to be able
to raise the next set of funds and you
know so that growth engine itself is a
little bit strange I mean even that is
because look that's that's the thing is
that if if it's if it's constantly about
returning the funds then some of the
ethos can become shaky if if it's if
it's that pressure that's coming to
return the money yes no I think it's
just it's just about choosing the
endeavors that you back so they are
doing then their commercial success yeah
yes which is you know it's not
impossible being vigilant doing the due
diligence to do exactly that so that
would be such an important part of what
I'm taking from this and hopefully
others are too is that if you to be so
first principle around the core pillar
of the ethos of building the new world
that it and that it never has to become
fragmented as you have to return the
money into the initial partners lp's
yeah that's the money in multiples in a
multiple not just yes like you return
the money thank you guys thank you it
was funny you know four to five times is
what they they hope as a sort of stable
stake and then maybe maybe there's some
flexibility in terms of maybe you only
return two times but you make
significantly more social impact on one
of the funds that you're yeah so there's
there's all these types things or maybe
you make ten times but you you were more
vigilant about the social impact side of
things I think possible everyone
everyone is super happy that you're
doing you're doing good as long as you
sort of meet their performance
expectations and you know what it's it's
completely feasible like I really sort
of think it's there's no trade-off I
mean there is some trade-off but you can
sort of figure out a way to perform for
your investors people interest you with
their capital
build companies that can make the world
a better place and then you can decide
to not invest in things that you don't
think are sort of own values and we do
that you know every day because for us
to get involved in a company one of us
this three of us Buckner is at work one
of us has to say yes I really excited to
go and spend time with this company and
help build it and I know it's going to
take ten years of my life to get it to a
launch outcome but I'm ready for the
challenge and I'm excited and you know
sometimes we meet a perfectly fine you
know idea great team interesting market
but no one has that sort of interest per
se so it's like hey anyone wants it and
we look at each other and we know that
it means well if no one would pick it up
the instant for us hmm and this is um
Ashley Cravens and Charles Hudson or the
other to know Ashley has been with me
for you know almost almost nine years
she's our director of operations Charles
is with your friend and was my first
partner uncork okay but he's really sort
of focused on what we call now proceed
which is uh a very very early stage
investing so my bombers are Stephanie
Palmieri and Andy mcLaughlin okay
Stephanie and Andy you know okay
interesting hopefully we can continue
doing things like sitting down with
partners at the different big VC firms
in Silicon Valley and help go through
these processes of unpacking their
journeys unpacking their relationship to
helping build that new world
I love I love doing this and hopefully
we can do it more and other people can
then gain the insights to also bring
their creativity to the world this is
really close to our hearts as well the
distribution of the rewards earlier we
were talking about
a micro-financing yeah that's very
interesting doing something like instead
of needing to put in 50 million into
your hey yeah fine it becomes something
like eight Alan do you have five hundred
bucks because of five hundred bucks you
can take you can invest in to uncork
apples fun this is because this is the
really hard thing we were talking
earlier about these cap tables and the
Securities and Exchange Commission and
blah blah blah this this part's really
hard to figure out but as we do figure
that out and maybe you know these these
decentralized immutable Ledger's become
part of the process that then you can
maybe make eight times on your 500 bucks
and you can really quickly find outlets
that are better than like you said stock
markets and for getting returns and we
can distribute rewards better yeah how
do you guys feel about about that
process and as emerging technologies
come into our world how to best like
include like an inclusive stake holding
mentality if like we always use this
example it's a very convenient one like
a ride-sharing company can the drivers
get part of the success can the riders
get part of the success can the
community that like the company operates
and can they get part of the sex can the
environment that can future generations
get part of the success that's I mean we
could spend two hours on that I think
that it would be it would be awesome if
we could sort of figure out a way to do
what you just described the challenge is
it's a very very complex regulatory
environment and we need the regulator's
to just define the rules because as much
as I would love to you know take 100
bucks from you know anyone and turn that
into four or five hundred the problem is
it takes ten years remember so you know
they may sort of not lie they may like
the outcome the minute like the time it
takes but at the end of the day we are
sort of regulated in a very very
specific environment and I can I can
actually not take you know money from
anyone who's not a accredited investor
and actually worse for us because our
fund is what we call Q P only so
qualified purchaser which means even if
you on a created investor if you don't
have
you know a lot of money then you can
invest with us because we decided to
because there are very specific rules
and limitations for example you can't
have more than 99 investors if ever you
go for a accurate investor sort of fund
whereas the kinds of funds like us don't
have it that limitation so we we
basically raise money from people who
have made a bunch of money themselves or
from institutions that by now 95 percent
of our capital comes from institutions
but if we I hope right D and and a lot
of sort of those advances in in
microfinance Louis to actually sort of
make money for these people and it could
be directly or indirectly and I'm pretty
sure at some point something's gonna be
figured out because there's no reason
that we can only serve with very
specific high performance financial
products that people already have a
bunch of money I think the one regret I
have is that you know we have a bunch of
family offices and funds of funds and
people were very proud to have as LPS
but I would have loved to have a you
know hospital so we could actually
return you know a bunch of money and
then see the impact that our financial
performance has on that community yeah
that's that's not my bucket list yeah
interesting yeah so there's all these
different ways to kind of codify the the
protocols and the structures that then
make it so that the emerging
technologies the financing of the
emerging technologies can then
distribute the rewards to more people
and to more on social good and that's a
huge part of our of our of our new
future that we will that we want to
build yeah one of the ones we were
mentioning this before we started but
interdependent capitalism redesigning
the social contract through inclusive
stake holding the incentive prize on
incentives these are all things of the
UN Foundation that we applied for and
that we always highly recommend our our
viewers to check out because that
style of a process is is so deeply part
of our social fabric of the future Jeff
I want to ask you also about what are
your thoughts on many of the cultures
around the world from we were to be
mentioned this a little bit earlier but
these ideas of the tribal days of the
immediate return hunter-gatherer days
there was this deep passionate
interconnectedness with each other and
the environment around us and it almost
felt like there was no set there was way
less separation the West brought in the
individual and it was both incredible in
many ways especially you know
entrepreneurially creatively but also it
created a more separation as well how do
you feel about our disconnection from
nature and its effects on the world that
we live in well I certainly that that's
that's an massive issue as we you know
we lived through massive wildfires which
have been created by you know climate
change in California and we are
unfortunately with the government which
has reaffirmed this morning that would
walk away from the Paris Accord right
and so that means that we don't care
about the environment I do think that
it's a shame that not more people
actually thinking about the world we're
gonna leave with our children I have you
know twenty two-year-old and nineteen
year old and yeah you know if you look
at the state of the planet that we leave
to them it's not brilliant at all and
unfortunately we don't see a ton of
entrepreneurs to focusing on that in
terms of major challenge and how to deal
with you know plastic pollutions or
things that there are a few but it tend
to be more on the nonprofit side and
that's that's always sort of something
which I find to be too bad is how can
you figure out how to do good and build
a sustainable so
you know company at the same time here I
don't I don't have an answer unless you
know we think about hey once we help
people will sort of make a bunch of
million and typically they stop being
more active in philanthropy and then
they start giving a bunch of that money
but that's that's that cycle is not
satisfactory I would I wish people sort
of could figure out how to you know
improve the environment while sort of
building sustainable sort of companies
interestingly you were talking about you
know companies building those meet at
alternatives and they are
it sounds like successful financially
while making the environment actually
sort of better because it comes you know
it comes from so many resources water
and electricity and so forth to to grow
meat versus those other products so I
think there are ways to find you know
mission and business and bring them
together and for certain things there's
just not gonna be we have to be leave to
be fine with the fact that there's not
gonna be a profit incentive and then we
need to create new funding vehicles for
those solutions and that's a whole part
of venture capital that needs in its own
way a new new vehicles within venture
capital that this is not something
that's a five times return after ten
years but this is something that is
funding is crucial science crucial
entrepreneurship crucial reconnection
back to our environment to nature
that is not something you're going to
get a return off of but is rather making
it so that our have our environment and
our interconnectedness with each other
is sustainable and prosperous for your
children and their children etc yeah and
unfortunately that the the way sort of
that that's what was I was talking about
what you have sort of venture capital
and and very specific sort of mandates
in terms of funding and will do really
crazy things but they have to build we
have to believe that they will build a
sustainable sort of company
at some point in the future even though
you know we've we've seen all those
companies who go public with massive
losses and and see all sort of making
more losses and you wonder like where
the sustainable part sort of comes from
and then there is you know fundamental
research which is typically sort of
government funded or you know
philanthropic sort of work like the
Gates Foundation and what's interesting
is this feedback loop where you see Bill
Gates
you know founding sort of Microsoft
becoming the number one number two sort
of wealthiest men on the planet
depending as to whether it's similar
just Bezos but then him through his
activity yeah we distributing I mean
he's committed to redistribute pretty
much everything is made for very key
causes where he will literally change
the face of actual disease thanks to the
funding gave for polio polio and things
like that and so think about malaria a
global impact on the worldwide basis
thanks to the work of one man who's made
a bunch of million billions and
super-smart and he's trying to take his
entrepreneurial sort of mindset and
applied to causes yeah so so that that
resource as long as you do it until
totally so there's funding vehicles
already like that now that you listed
yeah
and so then you know it's it's about you
go to Jeff Bezos and you grow like your
turn yeah so yeah yeah
that's a big part of it as well
completely agreed I want to know about
about your experiences with feelings of
non-separation and interconnectedness
how about your feelings with that have
you had experiences in that area on one
side
technology sort of makes us closer
because you can really sort of spend
like when almost 20 years ago we went to
visit my parents who live in a small
town of France called tool and we
brought them a computer didn't have a
computer and they're like what is that
and we're like well we're about to move
to Silicon Valley it's on the other side
of the planet will be nine hours ahead
of you guys or behind you guys and so
we'll talk through the computer and
we'll buy you know video cameras and
we'll use you know programs to talk to
each other because we won't be there
anymore
and you know I'm grateful for the
technology that allowed us to and in 20
years ago what you were seeing was very
grainy
he bit maps that were that were not you
know super high res but over time the
technology sort of improved then and now
we can do a pretty good so video
conference you know for an hour every
Sunday so we can spend them together so
I'm appreciated at connectedness the the
problem is that weird now is pushed it
to the extreme and you know literally
it's not uncommon to see two people
while having dinner and they sort of
just look at their phone respectively
and they don't even spend time together
and they don't make eye contact and do
anything you know like they don't they
don't share anything it's just like
there's a personal experience where I'm
here with my phone in my own world and
I'm not really sort of connected to the
reality I'm surrounded by and that I
despise may be something around craving
silence is one of the keys they're the
process of inspiring those feelings of
interconnectedness to all this to really
understand that the trees what they
breathe out I breathe in and the
cyclical processes that occur on the
planet like that
it's I think it's about one thing I've
sort of seen as a guru sort of older I'm
52 now is it's less about what you have
or own it's more about what you
experience and so now it's much more
about hey can we go and do something
together and experience something as
opposed to buy whatever look so like
okay well yeah we buy stuff because we
have to and you know our society is very
consumerist but I really sort of value
just the simple things of you know a
sharing a nice sunset or walk or being
somewhere together and do something yeah
yeah do you think these are some of our
ending questions that we love asking do
you think that humanity is a biological
bootloader for digital super
intelligence they would have wiped us
out I think they would be very
disappointed if it was true I'm sure
that would lead us because if you look
at what we've done to the planet the
superior human beings or superior
intelligence of superior AI that would
sort of look at our our output would say
okay let's just restart you know
sometimes you just say not working stuff
from a clean slate boom so do you think
it is our destiny to build that super
intelligence as biological humans
I don't think we'll build it by I will
stumble into it if we do a cricket tree
yeah like oh there was a bug and you
just created the singularity that
everyone is talking about what has been
your most profound experience in this
reality
Oh seeing my two children you know being
born and why because you suddenly you
sort of realized that she actually
created life and so I remember when I
when the first time I sort of held my
son on May 1st 1997 and he he was and
you know my wife and I had to discreetly
life does Berger though I was very
profound and I had the same feeling you
know when when my daughter was born here
Stanford is a great hospital by the way
yeah incredible sort of you know being
supported by them it's it's we've had
we've been fortunate to have a lot of
experience but I think nothing sort of
compares to having your firstborn or a
second born in in your in your arms yeah
yeah that's a frequent answer on their
program and too deeply profound one yeah
I'm surprised because I think you know
of all the things that you know you can
do as a human being giving life is the
most profound I would be curious what
people sort of saved they haven't had
children yeah yeah yeah because that
could be sort of a personal experience
could be a trip could be you know one of
the best memories I have of my travels
was being in in South Africa in the in
the Kruger Park just working around the
bush and and you know seeing all those
animals in their environment in the
purest most pristine kind of environment
it was just incredible
I wonder if Birds also think that when
they fly over cities and they're like
look at all those animals in that
environment it yeah you wonder and then
how about do you think that this is a
simulation do I think if it's a
simulation so
you know the matrix when the guys but to
eat the steak and to drink a very
expensive sort of of of Bordeaux and he
says I know that I'm programmed to sort
of like it but I still like it I'm a
huge wine fan so as long as I can
appreciate wine we'll be fine
on uncork but funny when you say that
yes the name of our firm is uncork but
it's really about and working innovation
and you know twists of energy that's
what this this means the twist of energy
when you open the bottle and the
uncorking innovation cooking innovation
yes
and the person who helped us rebrand
because before that we were called soft
egg we were rented two years ago is a
professor of branding at at Stanford and
he knew nothing about your MySite
passion for wine and Felicity had ten
names that were his recommendation and
the sixth was in Cork and he was
actually five you recommended in five
you would be happy with it was the
second column it was like why would
uncork be not your favorite because oh
my god this is so good
and it was that was slightly negative
fun and you don't want to have something
like a venture capital firm to have a
slight negative connotation but and and
we're just laughing because all of us
enjoy wine and we have more bowls of
wine the war office then the rest of
VC's combined yeah you know anybody
because you never know you may need four
hundred bottles of wine right why not
and that's where you know we decide to
go for uncork and and when we were
branded or founders sort of give us a
standing ovation because we announced it
at our fondo summit and they were so
happy that the Oval sub tech was gone
and then cork was was born Brendan yeah
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in this reality when you can
expense nature in a way where all the
downside and older you know stupidity of
us humans and and over the relations you
either don't see it or you're not
exposed to it that would be it so maybe
that is the new world where there isn't
that stupidity in those downsides but
that we have the problem is that we've
done so many bad things that getting
nature back to just an equilibrium
requires a work yeah and we talked a lot
about all the different ways that social
good comes out of what was happening in
venture capital and also about how these
new funding vehicles for inclusive stake
holding and all these other ways of
bringing forth the new world and
entrepreneurship such a critical pillar
in the building the new world Jeff thank
you so much for coming on our show thank
you for having me we was also new at you
coming on glad to hear that thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on that
so let us know what you're thinking
about investing in frontier tech and all
the other subjects that we talked about
in the episode of listeners your
thoughts also check out the links in the
bow below again to uncork capital calm
also Jeff's Twitter profile check those
out Thank You Horry Shapira
for co-producing thank you very much
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders in your
communities that you believe and support
them and help them grow around the world
you can support simulation all of our
links are below helped us grow help us
prosper as well and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace